what is something that people wait in
the truck for their sonic order
okay definitely Sonic uh they're like
they're drug dealers show up maybe okay
drugs and Sonic yeah
um
oh their wife anywhere their wife oh
yeah especially if you're like if you're
like the kind that's like I'm gonna go
wait in the truck so hurry up you know
and they're honking kind of dude which
was every dad I feel like oh yeah when
we were like an even like I mean you're
younger people when we were growing up
it was like every day I was like I'm
gonna wait yeah I want to be out of here
I heard a story about George Jones and
he like got tired of waiting on
um his current the wife that he died
with I can't remember her name uh I
should know that but that one time
he he wouldn't wait on her so he went
and sat in the car and laid on the horn
and she came out in her underwear and
got in the car and he was so fixated on
going wherever they were going he drove
all the way down the road and didn't
realize she was she was pulling one on
him because she was like well [__] you
then well I'll go wherever we're going
I'm going in my underwear if you can't
wait and even it went like five miles
down the road until he realized that she
was in her underwear and turned around
and came back
yeah that was always a thing I'm gonna
wait in the truck and you would just see
dads out there just
shaking their head what about like
you're like a little brother when your
Big Brother's like at baseball practice
you know like that type of deal oh yeah
I'm a Sit you would see that brother's
always just leaning yeah open on the
open window yep and then somebody would
come up and just like bang on the window
scared the [__] out of them yeah yeah
um what else do people wait for yeah
drugs for sure dude I uh waiting for
drugs is always scary it was always like
dude always always I always had to wait
what was the [__] deal why don't drug
yeah drug dealers are not punctual
no they're not dude even like weed
before weed was legal like I would have
panic attacks dude like he'd be like
show up here at three and I'd be like
all right cool and then and then like
dude it would be like 305 and I'm like
but you're like I don't want to piss my
drug dealer you know what I mean like I
don't want to piss my guy off but you're
like where the [__] are you at did you
get arrested like
are they are like in my mind it was like
okay the cops got him and they're like
all right go do the drug deal so we can
bust the guy like I have that's what
recording you know dude I remember this
guy I told us one time he's like yeah
meet me at this time so we get there
it's like a huge in the middle of this
Kmart parking lot right so we're like
we'll [__] pick up Corners they're
behind it it was just the worst idea
right so we so we we're like I remember
we drove around like just around the
middle for a while like I guess we might
want to go in it was like if we went
into the middle we were in trouble but
it was like we were just scoping I
thought it'd be less suspicious to just
make like a bunch of laps around the
parking lot oh dude the worst yeah I
remember one time we got some weed to
sell it right and it was like we were so
excited right we get this weed and the
second we got it we're like oh we're
going to [__] jail dude right so
we're so scared we're in the driveway we
finally ended up just giving the [__]
away to a guy down the street dude and
just ended up working the uh the payment
off
was it like a cop or was it like was it
like teenager a lot of like an ounce or
something no no I would say it was
probably yeah maybe a QP I think yeah
damn good hahaha damn dude gave it away
that was a good day for the guy you gave
it to though
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one